the first week of the trial saw some
emotional testimony
that was hard to listen to particularly
for some of george
floyd's family members who are here like
selwyn jones his uncle who i had a
chance to speak to
and this is a little bit of what he had
to say what is it like
to be here in that courtroom
this is all like a bad dream
you see somebody that you've loved and
cherished 45 46 years
and one day he's gone because of
just power and control this is this is
what
justice for floyd
we got to have justice for florida we
got to have justice for all
is it hard to relive floyd's death
through this trial this week i have
been sad
it's just like somebody sticks their
hand in your chest and rips your heart
out because
you see a good dude
human everybody has mistakes but you see
a good dude
if you've seen the video before uh he
was in the store
that's us laughing dancing hey you know
what i'm saying
and to know that he got killed murdered
for 19 and 100 pennies
you know so i'm not mad at any
individual person now
i'm mad at the system so if we can get
this done
and come to and you know come to a good
conclusion let's see if we can't fix the
system because
we have an opportunity for the first
time ever
to fix the system because of the death
of my nephew
the drug use how as a as his uncle
how does that make you feel when that
comes in
by the defense bringing up drug use a
is something that we live with
you know there's people with there's
people with so many addictions in this
world
and it's something that my man was
fighting you know what i'm saying
you should not be issued
a death sentence because you're high
simple
there's been plenty of people in this
world that's been hired before and they
didn't get murdered in the middle of the
street like a dog
so you know they're trying to
assassinate his character
but it's a proven fact you know he had
issues he had uh
you know he had demons but his demons
did not put him in a situation to be
killed because he wasn't fighting he
wasn't arguing
he wasn't doing any of the things that
you would
coincide with being murdered do you feel
confident
that you'll get a guilty verdict after
one week
not putting the heart before the cart
i'm not putting the cart before the
horse
we'll see like i'm saying i'm waiting uh
because uh
i've been living long enough now where
nothing surprises me
so i'm going to
wait and hope that things come out the
way they're supposed to
jones is one of several of floyd's
family members that are here
they say they'll stay for as long as the
trial takes
which could be up to another three weeks